Szeretném bizonyos szempontból
megnyugtatni a hallgatókat is, hogy egy
jó adag részét tudjuk delegálni az
AI-nak. Viszont az emberre mindig
szükség lesz. Az az én megérzésem túl
menően azon, hogy hogy most ezt a
gyönyörű szép gondolatot megfogalmazzuk,
hogy ön szerint miért lesz szükség az
emberre? Melyik azok a területek, amiket
sosem fog tudni az AI elvenni tőlünk?
Hát leegyszerűsítve a feladatnak a
meghatározása, promptolászem ezt
külföldi nyelv így hív, tehát hogy
valakinek meg kell mondani az eszköznek,
hogy mi az, amit te elvársz tőle, tehát
mi az, amire én őt használni akarom,
mert hogy ezt ő magától nem fogja tudni.
És ez szerintem ez a ez az a rész, ami
meg fog maradni mindig a mi
feladatunknak. [zene]
>> Sziasztok! Üdvözlök mindenkit! Ebben a
navigátor podcast epizódban egy
különleges helyről jelentkezünk be. A
digitális székelyföld konferencián
vagyunk, és a következő vendégem Dr.
Palkovics László lesz, [zene] a
mesterséges intelligencia stratégiáért
felelős kormánybiztos. Nagyon sok
mindenről beszélhetnék Dr. Palkovics
Lászlóról, ugyanis a hátterre hihetetlen
gépészmérnökként kezdte egyetemi tanár
Magyar Tudományos Akadémiának a tagja,
valamint a negyedik és az ötödik
orbánkormánynak a minisztere volt.
Ezenkívül az N7 Holding vezérigazgatója
is, és még sorolhatnám, de most
mindenképpen a mesterséges intelligencia
stratégiáról fogunk beszélgetni.
Rengeteg izgalmas kérdést fogunk
körbejárni. Úgyhogy gyertek,
csatlakozzatok és hallgassátok meg ezt a
köcsös beszélgetést. Dr. Palkovics
Lászlóval.
Üdvözlöm itt a kormánybiztos úr a
podcastünkben. Köszönöm, hogy elfogadta
a meghívást. Köszönöm a meghívást.
Üdvözlöm is a nézőket. A én vagyok nem
az avatárom. Csak azért volt fontos
tisztázni, mert technológia most már ott
tartunk, hogy több avatárt sikerül nekem
is használni, ha éppen nem tudok
valahova elmenni, és akkor de mégis
fontosnak gondolom azt, amit azt az
üzenetet, amit át akarnánk adni. Akkor
ezt egy avatárról oldjuk meg. Ez most én
vagyok fizikailag itt egyébként.
Úgyhogy, úgyhogy igen, miniszterelnök úr
hat hónappal ezelőtt kért meg arra, hogy
hát ez a mesterséges intelligencia, hogy
ez Magyarországben elég korán
szerepet vállalt, hiszen 2020-ban már az
első stratégiát elkészített kormány
akkor elfogadta, akkor éppen miniszter
voltam. Aztán 22 után egy kicsit
lelassult ennek a stratégiának az
implementációja.
Elég sok baja volt mindenkinek. Ukránosz
háború, energiaválság. több több ügy
volt, de újra koncentrálok erre a
területre, mert hogy a világ az viszont
rohamos léptekben halad halad előre. És
hát miniszterök úr azt kérte, hogy
próbáljam meg valamilyen formában a
Magyarországon mi történik, mi kell,
hogy történjen és mit kell tenni a
magyar közösségnek. Belértendő persze a
kormány is, de annak érdekében, hogy
Magyarország a mesterséges
intelligenciával kapcsolatos ügyeknek a
nyertese legyen.
Ne csak elviseljük, ne csak használjuk,
hanem akkor nézzük meg, hogy mik azok a
területek, ahol ahol egyébként hozzá se
tudunk ehhez valamit tenni. Na, ennek a
koordinációjával foglalkozom most, mint
kormánybiztos.
>> Ez egy hihetetlenül komplex feladatnak
tűnik nekem. Egy cég esetében. Egy ilyen
mesterséges intelligencia stratégiát
látok, belelátok én is személyesen is,
hogy hogy mennyire komplex már egy cég
esetében is, de egy nemzet esetében,
hogy fog neki valaki egy ilyen
stratégiának a kép.
>> Úgy mint úgy mint egy cégnél. Ugye én
21- néhány évet dolgoztam a német
autóiparba, és a fejlesztési vezetőként
a stratégia alkotás az nekem is
feladhatom volt. Tehát tehát ugyanazokat
az eszközöket használtuk egyébként, mint
egy cég esetében. Ugye egyik oldalról
persze bonyolultabb, mert mert több
szereplős és a szereplők azok nagyon
divzek egy cég esetében. Ugye vannak a
vevőink, vannak a beszállítóink, vannak
bizonyos partnereink. Hát egy társalom
esetében azért sokkal sokkal
bonyolultabb
a struktúra. A másik oldalról viszont
ugye itt azért egy ez egy fölé rendes
stratégia abban az értelemben, hogy ez
azért készül, hogy mindenki, aki aki
ebben érdekelt, a cégek, az intézmények,
akkor mindenki vezesse le a saját saját
fontos részét ebből a dologból. Tehát
ilyen m némileg egyszerűbb, tehát nem
egy k végrehajtatlan feladatot, ezt már
kétszer megoldottuk. Ugye tehát egy
hónappal ezelőtt jelent meg a
stratégiának az áldolgozása.
Ez a stratégia, ez úgy néz ki egyébként,
mint egy céges stratégia. Tehát tehát
meghatároztuk a víziót, hogyan gondoljuk
ezt létrehozni, mi a missziónk, utána
meghatároztuk azokat a azokat az
elérendő célokat, indikátorokat,
amelyek úgy gondoljuk, hogy a magyar
társadalmat jellemezni fogják. Hát ez
úgy gondoljuk, ez ugye mindig úgy
értelmezendő, hogy éppen most így
gondoljuk, de azért ez az egész terület
a mesters indeget olyan gyorsan
változik, és képes egyik napról másik
napra egészen más jellemzőket
produkálni. Majd mondok erre példát
később, hogy hogy ezt azért évente felül
kell vizsgálni legalább, hogy ezek a
célok, ezek még érvényesek. És akkor
utána megnéztük azt, hogy egyébként mi
szükséges ahhoz, hogy ezt a stratégiát
projektekre tudjuk bontani, és elkezdtük
ezeknek a projekteknek a csoportosítását
és a leírását. 10 nagy projektcsoportot
határoztunk meg, és valószínűleg nem
követtünk el nagy hibát, mert ez a 10
nagy projektcsoport, a 10 prioritása úgy
tetszik, na az Európai Unius két héttel
ezelőtt ezeket a prioritásokat határozta
meg. Tehát tehát úgy tűnik, hogy azért a
világ az egy irányba egy irányba próbál
bezűvel haladni. ebből a 10 pillérből
meg említen egy párat nekünk, hogy
>> igen, hát ugye mi azt mondtuk, hogy ugye
Magyarország akkor országon, akkor
viszont Magyarországnak és ilyen
értelemben aztán egész
középkelet-Európának beleértve egyébként
Szlovákiát, Romániát, Szerbiát, csak
Ausztriát, nekünk azért van olyan
jellemzőnk, amivel amivel ugye a
meghatározó szerepbe is tudhatunk
kerülni. Ugye ami ami ami az elmúlt 1000
év alatt a dokumentált történelmünk
alatt nem történt meg itt
közép-kedet-Európában itt és akkor
gondolok a nagy világégésekre a
népvándorlásokra a gazdasági struktúrák
átalakulására
az valószínűleg nincs a világon de ez
itt megtörtént és hát az egyik ilyen
nagyon fontos stratégiai terület hogy
hát akkor ezt használjuk ezt az adatot
tehát hogyha már vissza tudunk tekinteni
1000 évre vagyunk 500-ra akkor ezeket az
adatokat használjuk arra hogy a jövőre
vonatkozóan tudjunk predikciókat tenni
akár gazdasági akár kulturális
egészségügy zseniális terület, ami a
családfán keresztül látjuk, hogy milyen
betegség, hogyan öröklődik. Abbó
gyógyszert lehet fejleszteni. Tehát ez
egyik egyik ilyen terület, és ebben
közös ügyeink vannak. A másik terület,
ami szintén lehet persze közös ügy, hogy
hogy mit fog ez nekünk jelenteni. Tehát
ténylegesen a a mesterséges
intelligencia hol tesz bennünket
alkalmassá olyan feladatra vagy olyan
olyan dologra, amiben ma erősek vagyunk.
Ugye ezek az országok
mindegyike egy komoly iparral
rendelkezik. Rovánia is, Szlovákia,
Csehország, Magyarország, nagyon komoly
autóiparral, elektronikaparra
rendelkezünk,
tudunk autógyártani. Most kérdés az,
hogy jó, de mi a következő ilyen típusú
termelyik? És hogy adja magát,
viszonylag logikusan átgondoltuk, hogy
hogy ha a környezetünkben lévő eszközök
akik akik valami hasonló módon fognak
eljárni, mint amit egyébként mi is
akarunk, mert kommunikálnak,
kooperálnak egymással, mondjuk ezek a
robotok, hogy ezeknek a robotoknak a
gyártása az nekünk egy lehetőséget
jelent. vagy vagy nem. És hát ebből
viszonylag gyorsan lehet jönni, hogy aki
autót tud gyártani, az tud ilyen robotot
is gyártani, hiszen a ezeknek a
szenzorikája, az elektronikája, az
anyagfelhasználása, az energetikai
ügyeigik, az energiakonverziók,
ezek ezek ugyanak mint autóba. Tehát
akkor miért ne tudnánk? És akkor ez volt
a második terület, hogy akkor határozzuk
meg úgy a magyar
magyar gazdaság, a magyar akadémia, a
magyar kutatás terület jogszabályokat
például, hogy Magyarország legyen
attraktív azok számára, akik
Magyarországon ilyet akarnak fejleszteni
vagy gyártani. Itt a fejlesztés is
fontos. Ugye Magyarország autóipar
területén az elég komoly fejlesztési
kapacitással rendelkezik.
A számok csak, hogy valamit valamit
erről legyen. Elképzelésünk ez mit
jelent? Ö a GDP arányosan 0,18%-át
fordítjuk a GDP-nek csak autóipari
kutatásfejlesztésre. Úgyhogy milyen ez a
szám? Ez olyan, mint Ausztriában meg
Csehországban, és sokkal nagyobb, mint
mint Lengyelországban, sokkal nagyobb,
mint Szlovákiában, sokkal nagyobb, mint
Romániába, akik szintén komoly
autógyártókapacitással rendelkeznek.
Tehát Magyarország nem az összeszerelő
üzemeknek a hazája, bármennyire szereti
ezt néha az ellenzékünk mondani, de
hanem nagyon komoly innovációt is
elvégezni képes és elvégezni tudó
ország. Ez a kapacitás ez tökéletesen
alkalmas arra, hogy egyébként például a
humanoid robotok vagy ezen a területen
is egyébként meg tudjunk meg tudjunk
jelenni, hiszen nem nagyon különböznek
ezek egymástól.
>> Amikor először rákerestem erre a
kezdeményezésre, erre az ötletre
stratégiailag, hogy Magyarország egy
helyi centruma legyen a humanoid
robotoknak a a gyártására,
az első kritika, amit hallottam, az az,
hogy Magyarország egy újabb összeszerelő
műhelyé fog válni. Ennek önnek mi a
válasz? Az a helyzet, az a helyzet, hogy
ez azért nehéz mit kezdeni, mert azok az
emberek, akik ilyeneket mondanak, hogy
Magyarország ez egy ilyen összeszerő
üzem, nem tudom, hogy mire gondolnak
ilyenkor, hogy mi lenne, mi lenne a
másik alternatíva. Tehát most
Svédországban is gyártanak autót, nem?
Meg Svédországban is gyártanak acélt,
tehát van nehéz iparuk. Németországban,
de ettől ugyanez a helyzet. Ott meg se
mondani ilet összeszerű üzemtől, hogy
Magyarország miért lenne kevésbé vagy
nagyobb mértékben összeszerelő üzem,
mint ezek az országok. De hiszen ha
megnézzük mondjuk a BMW-nek a debreceni
gyárát, hát aki aki nem látott még ilyet
valószínűleg az mond ilyent vagy törsz.
a a az egy az egy komplett ökoszisztéma.
Tehát ma már az, hogy egy üzemet
képzelünk el, ami a ami a teleg végén
valamit gyártogat, ezek nem így néznek
ki. Tehát ezek köré komplett ügyek
épülnek. De ugye akkumulátor a másik,
ami amire azt szokták mondani, hogy hát
Magyarország miért döntött az
akkumulátor gyártás mellett, hiszen az
is csak egy összeszerelés. Na most ugye
nem tehát az a helyzet, hogy az
akkumulátorgyártás az egy olyan
ökoszisztémát épít föl, ami onnantól
kezdődően, hogy valamilyen nyersanyag
beérkezik, ez ügy általban problémánk
Európába, de onnantól kezdődően
gyakorlatilag minden lépésére képes
annak, hogy az akkumulátor az
elkészüljön, és utána ez az akkumulátor,
amikor majd a élet ciklusa a végére ért,
akkor újra tudjuk hasznosítani. Na most
ugye ilyenkor azt szokott elhangzni,
hogy ja de hát az akkumulátor az
energiaigényes meg munkaerőigényes, meg
szennyezi a környezetet, hátha
kiszabaduly gyárból persze. És akkor muk
megkérdezem ezeket, akik ilyenek
mondanak, és és akkor mondjuk a
félvezetőgyártás, ja hát a
félvezetőgyártás az más, hát az nagyon
innovatív. És mondtam, hogy na a kornak
itt van jelentősége, hogy amikor ugye a
huszon valahány évvel ezel Európából
elkezdtük elvinni a félvezetőgyártást
Ázsiába, három indoka volt annak, hogy
mit mondtunk akkor. Nagyon
energiaigényes a félvezetőgyártás,
veszélyes a félvezetőgyártás és
munkaerőényes. Ez azért elvittük
Tajvára, meg elvittük délkorába amit
most perszent bánunk, hiszen láttuk azt,
hogy milyen, amikor kiszolgáltottak
vagyunk. Tehát tehát mielőtt valaki
ilyet mond, hogy összeszerelő üzem meg
nem ezek politikai meg gazdasági
döntések, de amiket az ügyi döntés azok
át szoktak át szoktak gondolni, tehát
Magyarország nem összeszerülő üzem, vagy
ha az, akkor Németország meg Svédország
is az, merthogy merthogy ők ugyanezt
csinálják.
>> Ez az az első gondolatom, amikor a
mesterséges intelligenciával én is
találkoztam, az a félelem volt őszintén
szólva. Egy technikai háttérrel
rendelkezem, de de mégis a zsigeri
érzésben nem a félelem volt, hogy mi fog
történni. Egyrészt egyre gyorsul a
világunk, másrészt egyre komplexebbé
válik a világunk. És az egyik dolog,
amit látok, az az, hogy az emberi IKQU
az nem fejleszthető. Tehát hogy rontani
lehet rajta van egy limiteszteni. És
amit látok, az az, hogy a például a
világgazdasági fórum előrejelzései
alapján több munkahely fog születni,
mint amennyi megszűnik a mesterséges
intelligencia hatására. Tehát, hogy
ilyen szempontból oké, akkor akkor nem
az van, hogy munka nélkül maradunk.
Viszont az én megérzésem az, hogy azok a
munkahelyek, amik megszűnnek, azok
kevesebb ikút fognak igényelni, úgymond,
mint azok, amik születnek. A a az új
munkahelyek egyre nagy több kvalitást
fognak igényelni.
>> Igen, ez egy nagyon nagyon jó kérdés
egyébként. Tehát tehát tehát ez is lehet
egy megközelni, nem tudjuk, hogy így
lesz-e egyébként feltétlenül, tehát hogy
azok a munkáink, amik megjelennek,
azokat el tudják-e látni azok az
emberek, akik esetleg elvesztik a
munkájukat
a adott adott helyzetben, mondjuk a
mesterséges intelligencia miatt. De
ennek azért van egy másik megközelítése
is, ha már mondjuk mondjuk a a
kooperatív együttműködő ügyekről
beszélünk. Szóval ha megnézzük, hogy ma
hogy néz ki mondjuk egy gyármonik a
gyárn, mert olyan sokat beszéltünk, hogy
egy egy gyár egyébként azok már úgy
nagyjából automatizáltak, egy csomó
mindent nem is tudunk elvégezni.
De ilyen módon aztán miután a gyárak
azok tényleg egy automatizált hightech
irányba alattak el, azoknak a
munkásoknak, akik egyébként ott
dolgoznak, de az életük egyszerűbb lett.
Tehát korábban, amikor neki kellett
beállítani a gépet, akkor az az igényelt
egy sokkal magasabb szintű tudást. Na
most ezt a tudást ezt a gép maga
megoldja. Tehát másfajta tudásra lesz
szükség. Nem szükségszerűen fogják ők
azért azzal elveszít, hogy a tudás ez
mondjuk a Nobeldíjasok tudászintjét
kell, hogy megközelítse, mert effektíve
egy intelligens eszközzel mindig
egyszerűbb együttműködni. mint egy kevés
intelligens, viszont ott én nekem kell
meghatároznom, hogy mi történik. Szóval
ez nem biztos, hogy így van. Várjuk meg
ezt. Szerintem vagyunk elégendő
kreatívak ahhoz, hogy hogy ezt a
technológiaváltást is valahogy át
átéljük. Ugye mindig a félelem az az
ugye a munkánk félt és ez egy ez egy ez
egy természetes emberi reakció. Ugye a
angol géprombolók hát ők azért törték
össze a takácsok a gépeiket, mert azt
gondolták, hogy el fogja venni a az ő
egyébként nehéz, veszélyes, unalmas
munkáját, de mégis megtették. Aztán
utána persze a világ az tovább alakult
és nem volt igazuk. Ugye ahogy a másik
kettőben sem lett igazuk. Szerintem most
sem
>> homonoid robotokkal. Tehát ez egy
ameddig a mondjam úgy, hogy a nagynyelvi
modellek elkezdték veszélyeztetni a
meglepő módon a fehér galléros munkás
munkáját. Úgy látom, hogy a h homonoid
robotokkal egyszerre most már a
kékgaléros munkásoknak a munkája is az,
ami ami bizonyos szempontból
veszélyeztetve lesz. Vagy pedig a az
önvezető járműveket, hogyha tekintjük.
Most azt látom statisztikailag legtöbben
a a szállításiparban, amit sofőr
dolgoznak, hogyha arányait nézzük.
Erre hogy tud egy ország felkészülni?
>> Hát ugye az a kérdés, hogy mi indokolja
ezt, hogyha most maradjunk akkora
szállításnál, mert az egy jó példa erre
egyébként, hogy van-e elegendő most
teherautófőr, ugye nyilván a teherautó
az egy vagy a haszonyármű az egy olyan
eszköz, ahol az automatizálás az az egy
szükségesség. Van-e elég teherautó sofőr
Európában vagy Amerikában? Nincs. Mi a
következménye? Hát külföldről kell
hoznunk vagy hívnunk ide olyanokat, akik
egyébként sem a testatutokat után, sem
az attitűknünk fog nem biztos, ugye a
legoptimálabb jelöltek. Tehát egy 45
kg-s hölgyet beültetünk egy teherautóba.
Hát most ha kikecserni a gumit, mit
mihez kezd? Tehát tehát az ugye a
kényszer egyébként az egyik egyik egyik
komoly ügy, hogy hogy hát valakinek kéne
vezetni az autót. Vagy azért, mert nincs
mondjuk asszony jármas sofőr, de vagy
azért, mert öreg személy és egyébként
mondjuk a képességeim romlanak, de a
mobilitásigényem az hatalmas marad.
Tehát én én szeretek jönni, menni,
szeretek vezetni, de hát már érzemyú egy
60 fölött ezek ezek változnak ezek a
képességek, de tehát ott például az
összes olyan funkciót, ami ami az
autóban is létezik egyébként jelentős
mértékben, ezek a vezetőtámogató
adaszfunkciók, de ezek azért vannak,
hogy ne kövessünk el hibát. Nem beszél
arról, hogy hogy ugye tehát tehát tehát
az autóvezető munkáját, mint olyat eb
első körben támogatja, de ez semmiképpen
nem veszi el, hanem azt a hiányosságot,
vagy azt a hiányt pótolja, vagy azt a
hiányosságot pótolja, amivel amivel
rendelkezünk. Elbeszélve arról, hogy
mondjuk ha megnézzük az európai
számainkat, hát európai az európai
társam elöregszik. Ilyen módon aztán ha
mobilitási igényünket meg akarjuk vagy
ki akarjuk elégíteni, és mondjuk autóval
akarjuk, tehát nem akarunk villamossal,
busszal, vonattal menni, hanem az autó
adta szabadságot, azt meg szeretnénk
tartani, de a képességeink azok már nem
annyira jó, akkor valamit ki kell ebbe
találni. Ugye az a kérdés inkább, hogy
például ilyenkor az autóba, tehát egy
autonóm autóba milyen olyan funkciókat,
milyen olyan featuröket építünk be,
amivel el tudjuk tölteni az időt, akkor
mi egyébként nem vezetünk. Az, hogy
ebben van másfajta kényszer is, az is
látszik nagyjából. Ugye 2050-re Európai
azt a célt tűzte ki, hogy ne halljon meg
Európában senki közlekedési baleset
következményeképpen vagy közlekedési
balesetben, ami most már nagyjából
látszik egyébként technológia nélkül el
fog menni. Tehát tehát ott a baleseti
helyzetet mindenképpen el kell tudni
kerülni. Nem, tehát ott sem oktatással,
sem rendőri eszközökkel elértük a
limitet, tehát nem nem fogunk tudni nem
fogunk tudni efé menni jelentősen. Egy
eset vagy egy esélyünk van, hogy akkor
ezt megoldjuk valamilyen módon, de
mondjuk a közlekítés automatizása az
autóizásával. Tehát, hogy ezek mindig
összetett összetett dolgok. A félelmet
én nem javasolnám. Ugye volt ilyen
félelmünk is, hogy a és nem is nem is
automatizálásról van szó, hanem a
mondjuk a közösségi eszközök használata.
Ez a sérdekonomi körébe tart ez az a
dolog, hogy ki fog autót venni, hogyha
egyébként a Mol Limóval Budapesten csak
beülök és megyek. Nem változtatta meg a
helyzetet, tehát megélnek egymás
mellett, mindenkinek vannak bizonyos
igényei. Ez valamilyen módon kielégíti,
de nem nem történt semmi fajta tragédia,
amit egyébként mondjuk akkor gondoltunk.
Úgyhogy, úgyhogy én most ezt a világvégi
hangulatot, hogy majd a robotok elveszik
a munkámat, meg az autonomautót, nem
kell vezetnem, mert nem lesz benne
kormány. De ezeket azér mindig csak
módjával ezek olyan ügyek, amit azért
csinálunk, mert nekünk jó legyen. Nem
semmiképpen nem magunk ellen fejlesztünk
mondjuk egy ilyen robotot, de hanem
hanem azért, mert támogat bennünket.
>> Tegyük fel, hogy tényleg ezek jó dolgok.
Egy kicsit még játszom az ördög
ügyvédjét.
Az egyik gondolatom az, hogy Amerika és
Kína mellett most hol van Európa? Le a
nagyon jó dolgokból vajon nem-e maradunk
le így európaiak? Ha most az innovációt
tekintjük, a legnagyobb, legtöbb
innováció most ebbe a ebbe a két régióba
történik, és és most hol látja a
kormánybiztos úr Európát?
>> Alapvetően alapvetően ugye Európa az egy
másfajta szerkezet, mint akár Kína, akár
Amerika. Oltatlanul ugye azt szokták
mondani, hogy a nagy technológiai
területek jelentős részébe
Kína meghatározó, Amerika a második,
Európa meg nem is nagyon szerepel. Ez ez
ténylegesen ténylegesen így van. Tehát
az Európai Unió ugye ez 27 országot
jelent. Tehát persze könnyű azt mondani,
hogy de miért nem úgy működünk, mint
Kína vagy Amerika? Hát azért, mert itt
27 ország van, 27 különböző nemzettel,
27 nyelven, 27 jogrendszerrel, 27
döntési mechanizmussal, de nyilvánvalóan
nem tudunk olyan módon működni, mint
mint ahogy egyébként mondjuk Kína
működik ugye egy másfolytatásra
berendezkedési ország, vagy a
magazdasági súlyával az Egyesült
Államok. Tehát óhatatlanul vannak
dolgok, ahol ahol ahol nem tartunk ott,
ahol egyébként ők tartanak, de vannak
olyanok, am tartunk előrébb. Tehát
igazán igazán igazán én ezt nem látnám
megint ilyen világvége hangulat
különössen nem a mesterséges
intelligencia területén ugye mi
meghatározóit alapvetően meghatározó az
adat tehát rendelkezünk elegendő adattal
ahhoz
bárhol mit történelünkben, aktuális
operációk működésünkben, ami adatot
tudunk arra használni, hogy erre ezen
megoldásokat csináljunk. Igen,
rendelkezünk adatokkal. Tehát ráadásul
az európai 27 országnak a 27 különböző
típusú adatstruktúrája az egyfajta
robosztusságot is jelent, meg egyfajta,
hogy mondjam, ugye az adat az nem csak
az adat, amin egyébként a chat GPT-t
föltanítják és az interneten előadatok,
hanem hát például a levéltárakban lévő
adatok, azok ugyanide tartoznak.
Magyar levéltárnak asszem 300 kmnyi
papírja van, ami adatokat tartalmaz az
elmúlt 1000 évről. De most ezeknek az
adatoknak a feldolgozása az lassan meg
fog kezdődni, mert egyszerűen az
interneten elérhető adatok, amik
egyébként tartalmát illetően jelentős
veszteséget szenvedtek akkor, amikor oda
fölkerültek valamilyen formába. Tehát
ebben például Európa kifejezetten komoly
helyzetben van már csak azért, mert 1000
éve itt vagyunk és hát 1000 éve gyűjtjük
az adatokat szemben mondjuk a más
országokkal. Most Kína mióta gyűjti, ezt
nem tudom. Nyilván ők egy hosszabb
történmel rendelkeznek. Tehát Amerika
nem tudott ott 1000 éves adatok
gyűjteni, mert hát nem létezik azóta az
ország. Tehát az alatt az egyik kérdés,
a másik kérdés a számítási kapacitás
meg az ekörépülő ökoszisztéma.
Oltatlanul a nagy számítóközpontok azok
azok alapvetően Amerikában vannak meg
Kínába. De azért a világ negyedik
legnagyobb számítási kapacitásával
mondjuk Németország rendelkezik.
Azérichi
adatközpont ilyen egy exzafor környéki
kapacitással bírnak. És ezt egyébként
fejlesztjük. Tehát ebben van egy
következetes
következetes döntés Európában, és abban
is, hogy ezek az alattközpontok, ezek
lehetőség szerint ne egy nagy valamink
legyen, hanem minden ország rendelkezzen
ilyen ilyen típusú adatközponttal. De
ugye a a Euro HPC az egy pályázati
konstrukció, ami az országokat támogatja
abban, hogy nagy teljesítmény számítókat
vegyenek. Mi is fogunk egyébként. És
utána pedig azt is támogatja az Európai
Unió, hogy ezen adatközpontok köré egy
ökoszisztémát építsünk vállalatokból,
egyetemekből. kutatóintézetekből,
állami intézményekből, akik használják
ezt a ezt a ezt a számítási kapacitást
arra, hogy a sajátikait feldolgozzák, és
ebből megoldásokat állítsanak elő. Tehát
ebbe szerintem Európa pont olyan
esélyekel rendelkezik, mint egyébként
bárki más. Ha ha mutatókat nézünk, hogy
a vállalatok hány századé használ
Európába, Amerikába vagy Kínába a abból
lehet, hogy le vagyunk maradva, de ezek
nem olyanok, ami nem behozható. Meg
tulajdonképpen most azt kell mondanom,
hogy a versenyképességünket
ugyan befolyásoljuk, de ezt meg tudjuk
mi is csinálni, eg dönteni, és akkor
majd valami történik. Ugye említettem
ezt a 10 területet, amit
amit amit a magyar kormány kormányzó
körül meghatározott, hogy akkor ezeken a
területeken kezdjük meg elsőként a
stratégia lebontását. Na, az EU
egyébként pont ugyanezt a 10 vagy 11
területet határozta meg, tehát teljesen
az egyezés. Igaz, hogy mi ezt korábban
csináltuk, lehet, hogy a Brüsszelben
lemásolták, ezt most nem tudom, de
mindenképpen jó úgy, ahogy van. Tehát,
hogy az látszik, hogy Európa ebben ezen
a területen föl fog zárkózni. És és hát
ami ami ami mondjuk ezt lehet pozitívan
meg negatívan is nézni, hogy Európa ugye
volt ez a vicces mondás, hogy mi itten
szabályozgatunk, amíg a többiek meg
fejlesztenek. Én azt nem látom
problémásnak egyébként, hogy egy ilyen
bonyolult szerkezetben, mint az Európai
Unió, tehát ez a 27 ország, 27,
hogy ebbe azért van egy bizonyos
minimális szabályozás. Ugye az EU-nak a
az AI szabályozása az egy rizikóalapú
szabályozás jelent, hogy milyen rizikót
jelent tennek bizonyos kategóriák. Ö
amit meghatároztunk, ez rendben van.
Nyilván elfogadhatatlan mértékű rizikót
jelentő megoldásokat senki nem akar,
mert miért akarnák hát ez bocsánat,
lükkeség. összes többit meg ki lehet
elégíteni. Tehát tehát ha le akarom
egyszeríteni, akkor azért, mert az AI
act az implementációra került, vagy
kerül folyamatosan, de ez nem fog
bennünket meggátolni, hogy mondjuk itt
itt Erdélyben valamelyik IT cég
bármilyen megoldás még kifejlesszen.
Nyilván senki nem akar mondjuk
társadalmi csoportokat megfigyelni.
társadalmi pontozást bevezet, mert ezt
tiltja a legmagasabb szint. És mondjuk
azok a megoldások, ahol az embert tudat
alatt vagy ember csoportunkat tudat
alatt akarunk befolyásolni valamilyen
negatív dolgok irányába, ezt sem
akarjuk. Ezt a hármat nem akarjuk, akkor
inétkez minden szabad. Néhány szabályok
van, de ezek nem gátolnak semmit.
>> Akkor a kormánybiztos úr optimista
Magyarországgal kapcsolatban is, hogy
van időnk felzárkózni, van van lehetőség
csinál csin tehát egy egy dolog nagyon
fontos, hogy ugye az, hogy
Magyarországon ilyenfjta megoldások
lesznek, az egészen biztos. Tehát tehát
tehát az, hogy ezek a megoldások a
cégeken keresztül megjelennek, bejönnek,
alkalmazzuk őket, az összes Google,
Microsoft egyéb más, ezek ott vannak.
Ugye az a kérdés, hogy tehát ez nem
kérdés, ezek lesznek. Ugye az a kérdés,
hogy a magyar gazdaság az hogyan tud
ebből profitálni, tehát hogy mondjuk
Magyarországon működő IT vagy nem IT
cégek lesznek-e azok, akik megoldásokat
fejlesztenek, vagy ezt ráhagyjuk a
Google-re meg a többire? Ha ráhagyjuk,
akkor akkor is fogunk ilyet csinálni. Ez
nem kérdés, de hogy tesszük is ezt ma
egyébként, de akkor abból kevesebbet
profitálunk. De hogy megtörténik, az
egészen biztos. Itt az a kérdés, hogy a
mi gazdaságunk szempontjából vagyunk
ebben a helyzetben, hogy ezt egyébként
kézbe tudjuk tartani. Ha igen, akkor
viszont akkor viszont ugye ezért fontos
a stratégia, amit ebbe leírtunk, azt
próbáljuk teljesíteni. Akkor viszont
akkor viszont jobban fogunk ebből
kikerülni. Tehát én nem látnék ebbe ebbe
ebbe problémát. Ha megnézzük a a
szintekbe lehet vitatkozni, hogy akkor
most a magyar vállalatok digitalizációs
szintje az milyen? De mondjuk a magyar
egyetemnek a magyar állam digitalizálts
foka az olyan, mint a többi állami
környéket. Tehát nagyon különbözik
azért, mert ezek a megoldások ezek
léteznek. Az nem mindegy, hogy ki
csinálta ezeket, illetve ki az, aki
működteti, meg hogyan használjuk.
>> Az egyik kérdés, ami felmerül bennem, az
az, hogy most kicsit a pozitív oldalról
is beszélve,
>> én egy pozitív voltam meg.
>> Igen, azt láttam, azt látom. És és a a
pozitív hangok, a csalogató hangok azt
mondják, hogy annyival nőhet ezáltal a
produktivitásunk, hogyha AI eszközöket
kezdünk majd alkalmazni, meg honoid
robotokat, hogy lehetséges, hogy elérjük
azt, hogy egy négynapos munkahetünk
legyen.
Ez mennyire valóság ön szerint?
>> Hát ugye a produktivitásnak a növekedése
sokféleképpen el megtörténhet. Ugye
vannak országok Ausztria például ilyen,
ahol a munkaerőnek a a hatékonysága, a
produktivitása az olyan magas, hogy
tulajdonképpen ők négy nap alatt is
tudják teljesíteni azt, amit egyébként
most öt nap alatt teljesítenek. Tehát
nem nem ez nem egy eredetnek nem egy
eredetnek gondolat. Az, hogy az
embereknek több ideje marad magukra, az
meg szerintem szintén nem eredetne a
gondolat. Tehát tehát tehát én ezt
annyért nem látom problémának. Ilyenkor
a cinikusem azt gondolja, hogy valakinek
nő a produktivitása és felszabadul
ideje, akkor valószínűleg több munkát
fog vállalni.
>> Hát az a másik lehetőség, de ezt
mindenki döntse el magának. Tehát hogyha
ugye emlékszünk arra hát én még
emlékszem rá, hogy a ott a 80-as évek
elején, hogy is volt a szombat, az még
munkanap volt.
>> Szombat munkanap volt.
>> Szombat az mer összefolyt, hogy mikor
volt ez. De szombat munkanap volt. Aztán
most már szombat nem munkanap. És hogyha
megnéz technikailag már a péntek is csak
úgy félig munkanap, mert egyszerűen az
eszközök miatt, a tudások miatt nőtt a
produktivitásunk. Ezt én nem látom
önmagában bajnak. A munkának a megléte
és a munkáért kapott jövedelem. Na ez
egy fontos dolog. Aztán hogy ez most
négy nap alatt vagy öt nap alatt
végződik el, az egy másik kérdés.
>> Ezt gondolom arra érti a kormányz, hogy
az az egységes alapjöv azzal én nagyon
nem értek egyet. Egyszerűen egyszerűen
egyszerűen a nekünk a természetünk az,
hogy valamit csináljunk, tehát hogy
dolgozzunk és azért fizetést kapjunk. De
a az alapjövedelmet ezt nagyon rossz
megközelítésnek tartom. Tehát hogyha ha
mondjuk egy ilyen vita odamen neki, hogy
hát használjuk robotokat és mi kapjunk
alapjövedelmet, mert a robotok azok
megteremtik egyébként is azt majd amit
na ez egy buta megközelítés. Tehát ott
viszont el fogunk veszíteni csomó
mindent. Tehát amit nem csinálunk, van
ilyen szabály, amit nem csinálunk, azt
nagyjából nagyjából két hét alatt
elfelejtjük.
>> Ez igaz a vállalatokra, igaz emberekre,
hogyha nem nem szembesülünk ügyekkel,
akkor akkor azt elfelejtjük és konz át
fog alakulni. Meg talán a lelki
egészségünkért is fontos az, hogy
valamiért hasznosnak érezzük magunkat és
nem csak érezzük, hanem valójában
hasznos is legyen, amit csinálunk.
>> Így van. Meg meg meg illúziónk. Szóval
mindent nem fognak elvégezni helyettünk
a robotok meg a meg a meg a gépek meg a
különböző elemek. Effektíven azért, mert
ugye azt mondjuk, hogy ez mesters
intelligencia, de hát ugye ez alapvetően
inkább egy intellektualizált környezetet
jelent.
Nem intelligens gépekről beszélünk. Ugye
az emberi intelligencia az egy másfajta
dolog, de az nem olyan, mint amint egy
gép csak azzal, hogy hogy képes arra,
hogy múltbeli ügyekből tanuljon, és ez
alapján hozzátegyen valamit a jövőhöz.
Ettől nem fog azzal az intellektussal
rendelkezni, amivel rendelkezünk mi. Ma
hangzott el egy nagyon jó példával, nem
is gondoltam rá, hogy ugye jogvégzett
emberek ők ők azt mondják, hogy hát
azért most azt a sok jogi munkát, amit
én ma elvégzek, ezt el tudja végezni a
CG GPT is, vagy el tudja végezni egy
erre fejlesztett rendszer, hogy mi is
csinálunk ilyet. egy programunk az a
igazságügy minisztérium magyar
joggrendet föltanította egy ilyen regnek
és és ez jövő tavasztal elérhető ezt
mindenki számára. Hát igen, egészen
odáig, amíg a múltbeli tehát a tényleges
adathalmaz alapján, tehát mondjuk a
magyar jogtár, a múltbeli tapasztalatok,
tehát amit mondjuk a a bírósági
döntésekben, önkormányzati döntésekből
leírtunk, azon alapján valóban képes
lesz kérdésekre válaszolni. Na amikor
ott állunk a tárgyalóteremben és mondjuk
mondjuk a ügyfelem érdekében, hogy
mondta képviselő úr, nem akarok csúnyát
mondani, de azt mondta, hogy nem mond
igazat feltétlenül, hogy az igazságot
már szöbbe na ezt egy cse csipíti, hogy
fogja megtenni tehát hogy szóval van egy
van egy sor része az életünknek, ami még
abban a munkakörben, amit esetleg
veszélyezted, valamifajta emi
alkalmazás, még abban a munkakörben sem
értelmezhető. Ugye mérnöki munka
tipikusan ilyen. Ugye a mérnökök
mérnökök izgulhatnak, de hát izgultunk
egész hetig. Hát most ilyen 2000-es
évekén ugye egy szoftverfejlesztő
intézetet vezetem, amikor amikor is
megjelentek az automata kód generátorok,
tehát ami a funkcionális szoftverből itt
egy magas szintű nyelven megírtunk,
abból az adott autóipari vezérlőegység
kontrollerére egy target specifikus
kódot generált, mert egyébként ezt
eszemblében kellett volna átfordítani.
Na most aki tudja, hogy mi az eszemblé,
hát maga már valószínűleg nem tudja,
mert túl fiatal de hogy nem én dolgoztam
>> még dol. Na, tehát lássuk be, azért az
sok mindennek nevezhető, de néhány
nagyonnagyon white fül, hogy mondjam,
félzseni szoftverfejlesztőn túl azt
azért kevesen élvezték. Igen, mert
>> na de ki is halt. Miért halt ki? Hát
azért halt ki, mert egyszerűen nem volt
hozzádott értéke ilyen értelemben, mert
mert egy kódgenerátor meg tudta tenni
ezt a dolgot. Most ugyanezt elkövetjük
már, már kódolnunk sem kell. Megint ugye
kérdés, hogy kódolás művészete meg
kódolás szépsége mi is szép és mi is
művészet abba. Az, hogy egyébként a
specifik pontosabban a követelményeket
összeálltam, na az igen, mert az az
igen, intellektuális tevékenységet, a
többi az egy az egy az egy az egy
eljárás alapján, hogy kell szoftvert
fejleszteni.
>> Tehát ilyen szempontból akkor az AI,
amit el tud venni tőlünk maga a gépies
megismételhető sem tervezés az, tehát
azt nem meg az interpretáció a végén.
Tehát, hogy egy mérnöki most van között,
ha el akarunk végezni mondjuk egy egy
áramláslani számlítást, akkor nem a Navi
Stok egyet kezdjük el megoldani, mert
azt nem tudjuk minden feltételmelt,
hanem egy CFD szoftver, azt majd elvégzi
szám vagy elvégzi helyetünk, sokkal
pontosabban, sokkal gyorsabban, sokkal
jobban megteszi, de nekünk kell
meghatározni a modellt magát, tehát hogy
igazán igazán igazán a az algoritmus,
tehát hogy mit várunk el attól, amit
amit vajag gépére fog hozni. Na azt
nekünk kell meghatározni. És igazán ez
intellektuálisan az érdekes része.
>> Ez ez a tényleg így van, hogy
technológia téren ez igaz, de most
szeretném bizonyos szempontból
megnyugtatni a hallgatókat is, hogy egy
jó adag részét tudjuk delegálni az
AI-nak. Viszont az emberre mindig
szükség lesz. Az az én megérzésem, ami
nyilván. De hogy hogy túlmenően azon,
hogy hogy most ezt a gyönyörű szép
gondolatot megfogalmazzuk, hogy ön
szerint miért lesz szükség az emberre?
Melyik azok a területek, amiket sosem
fog tudni az AI elvenni tőlünk? Hát
leegyszerűsítve a feladatnak a
meghatározása, promptolás, azem ezt
külföldi nyelv így hívják, tehát hogy
valakinek meg kell mondani az eszköznek,
hogy mi az, amit te elvársz tőle, tehát
mi az, ami mi az, ami mi az, amire én őt
használni akarom, merthogy merthogy ezt
ő magától nem fogja tudni. És ez
szerintem ez a ez az a rész, ami ami ami
ami meg fog maradni mindig a mi
feladatunknak. Igen. Tehát a a
computation versus comprehension, tehát
az értés, a dolgok a dolgoknak a
megértése az teljesen megértése, tehát a
feladatnak a megértése, tehát hogy mit
akarok csinálni és a végén pedig annak a
megértése, hogy ami elkészült, az
megfelel-e annak a követelménynek, amit
én meghatároztam.
>> És akkor itt bejön a felelősségvállalás
is, hogy egy gépnél nem értelmezett az,
hogy felelősségvállalás.
Ez ez csak egy emberi dimenzió a
felelősségál. De de de technikailag
azért mi váljuk a felelősséget. Tehát a,
hogy mondjam, egy autonom autót, azt nem
fogok elküldeni magában, hogy
autózgasson egy kicsit, mert minek? Hát
az azért fog elmenni, mert én benne
ülök. Na innentől kezdve a felelősség,
tehát annak adajöttésnek a felelőssége,
hogy el akartam menni valamit valahova,
az részben az enyém is. Lehet, hogy nem
én vezetem az autót, lehet, hogy a hibát
azt máshol követték el, de én részese
vagyok ennek az ügynek, hiszen miattam
ment oda az az autó. És ugye ilyen
értelemben nekem továbbra is
felelősségem van abban, hogy ezeket az
autókat, ezeket mire fejlesztik.
függetlenül attól egyébként, hogyha nem
én voltam az, aki a hibát elkövette, és
ugyanez igaz, aztán így tovább lehet
vinni a robotokra meg bármi másra is, de
ugyanez igaz pont erről beszéltünk, hogy
hogy ez a hallucinációk nevezett
jelenség, amikor ugye egy jellem, egy
nagy nyelvű modell, h ezt arra készítik,
hogy ez mindenképpen minden körülmük
válaszoljon a kérdésre, és hogyha nem
tud, akkor bátran, mint egy ilyen
zseniális hazudozó válaszol, és akkor
megkérdez de nem akkor volt. Ja, tényleg
nem akkor volt. Akkor elnézé, és akkor
módosítom. Szóval, hogy hogy ez ez a
rizikója valamilyen szinten persze
mindig meg meglesz, és azért valakinek
felelősséget kell vállalni, és nyilván a
felelősség azért,
>> aki használja azt,
>> aki használni akarja, mert hiszen én
fogok ezzel valamit kezdeni, utána ő nem
magától talál ki valamit, hogy aztán
utána ezzel elmegy, és akkor majd valami
döntés okozni, hanem hanem hanem
miattam. Ez az én felelősségem és a
felelősség ez meg fog modadni.
>> Lassan a végére érkeztünk a podcastnek,
lenne még két kérdésem. Az egyik az,
hogy mit üzenne a mostani fiataloknak,
hogy mit érdemes tanulni és kié lesz a
jövő. Ugye ilyenkor sokfajta kérdés van,
öterjedt az a hír, hogy nincs szükség
informatikusokra, tehát nincs szükség
olyan emberekre, akik akik ezt a
digitális világ digitális világot értik
és hozzá tudnak szólni, ezt ne higgyék
el. Tehát tehát továbbra is
informatikusokra, az informatikához
értő, a számításhoz értő mesterség és
intelligenci azz értő szakemberekre
ugyanolyan módon lesz szükség. Ugye egy
vállal le akar építeni mondjuk szoftver
fejlesztőket, mert éppen nem kell neki
akkor egyszerű azt mondani, hogy na de
mert majd a CH GPT kódol nekem ezért
történek.
>> Akkor ez egy mondva csinált indok most a
darab darabonként darabonként kell
megnézni, hogy mi miért történik.
Nyilvánvalóan ezeket az eszközöket
valakik fejlesztik, ezek meg
informatikusok. Tehát szerintem az
informatika mint mint mint terület, ez a
tovább is érdekes terület. Ö, ami ami
ami ami szerintem az elkövetkezőket
nagyon meg fogja határozni, ez ez a
biomolekuláris
technológiáknak a kérdése. Tehát az egy
olyan dolog, amit amit én azt gondolom,
hogy tanulnék. És is gépészmérnök, mert
hogy én ez vagyok. Tehát az ilyen, de de
a viczet véretével, tehát az
informatika, illetve a a biológia,
biotechnológia, tehát ennek különböző
leképeződés formái vannak. Szóval ez
mindenképpen mindenképpen egy
perspektívus terület. Az egyik
intuitív megérzésem az, hogyha a ezt az
oldalunkat, a a gépies oldalunkat
delegáljuk a mesterséges
intelligenciának, tehát hogy már gyököt
most sem von senki, de egyre komplexebb
gépies feladatot át tudunk majd adni a
mesterséges intelligenciának, akkor
valójában az van, hogy fel fog erősödni
az emberi oldalunk. Tehát minden, ami
emberi, minden ami empátia, például
felelősségvállalás,
stratégia, a dolgoknak a a holisztikus
megértése, ezek fel fognak erősödni. És
bizonyos szempontból a bölcsészkaron
tanult dolgok, a filozófia, a
pszichológia, ezek a a az ágak fognak
majd a történelem
újra fel egy új adventét fogja élni.
Ennek mi a véleménye erről?
>> Ez abszolút, ez abszolút így van. Tehát
ha megnézzük, hogy ugye a nagy kihívások
azok ma hol vannak a technológia
területén, vagy pedig vagy pedig
a mondjuk a humántudományok területén,
akkor a humántudományok területén. Tehát
igazán igazán például a mestersköss
intelligenciával kapcsolatos kérdések
nagyon jelentős része nem a számítási
teljesítmény meg nem a nem a
matematikája bár azzal még van mit van
mit tenni, hanem a jogi kérdések, az
etikai kérdések jelennek meg, amire
nincs triviális válasz. Jogi sincs
egyébként bár az még egy viszonylag
körülhatárol dolog. etikai területen
pedig Magyarország ugye most készíti az
ELT rektora vezetésével az mesterségűs
intelligencia nagyon fölé rendelt etikai
kódexét, amit aztán majd mindenki maga
számára alkalmaz vagy alkalmaz. Tehát,
hogy inkább ezek a területek, amik amik
amik amik itt érdekesen jelennek meg. De
egyébként, ha mondjuk ez a nagy hát nem
is tudom minek hívjuk, nem akarom nyelvi
modellnek kívül, mert ez nem nyelvet
jelent, vagy nem elsősorban nyelvet
jelent, ez a magyar történelmi modell
kérdése, hogy mit tudunk a módból
tanulni, és hogyan tudjuk ezt valamilyen
formában megassítani. Ebben is főképp
egyébként nem matematikusok szerepelnek,
őnekik a vége lesz majd érdekes ott,
hanem hanem hanem történészek, akik
akiknek érteni kell ezt a adott
környezetet, jogászok, tehát tehát
másfajta, tehát humán human területre
talódott el a dolog, és ez egyébként
egyre inkább látszik sok területen.
>> Kormánybiztos úr, köszönöm az idejét.
Ennél optim optimistább és kerekebb vége
nem is lehet ennek a beszélgetésnek és
köszönöm, hogy elfogadta a meghívást.
>> Köszönöm a meghívást.
>> Köszönöm szépen.
>> Köszönöm. Az utóbbi időben nagyon sokat
foglalkoztat a startupok világa, nagyon
sokat foglalkoztat az oktatást téma, és
a következő pár epizódomat erre
szeretném szentelni, meghívni a legjobb
vendégeket, akik meg tudnak szólalni
ezekben a témákban. Ha szeretnél
támogatni ebbe a munkába abban, hogy
ezeket a témákat minél inkább ki tudjam
bontani, és a mögöttük rejlő alapelveket
meg tudjam érteni, és ezt podcast
formájában veletek is megosszam, [zene]
azzal tudtok támogatni, ha feliratkoztok
erre a csatornára. Azt vettem észre,
hogy körülbelül 80%-a a nézőknek nincs
feliratkozva a csatornára. Gyertek és
iratkozzatok fel. Ez [zene] nagyban
segít és motivál engem is, hogy tovább
folytassam ezt a kutatást, és ezeket az
érdekes témákat hozzátok is elhozzam.